I think in this country we have have an
issue with being honest with ourselves
we have an issue with being honest about
who we are what is transpired over the
course of our history to marginalize
groups of people and I think what often
happens is that we get a a diluted or
myopic or very one dimensional
perspective on and what is taking place
over the course of our nation's history
I remember receiving the news when
tomato rice was killed a twelve-year-old
boy in Cleveland who was shot four in
the park playing with a toy gun police
killed him within two seconds of pulling
up in the car and it immediately brought
me back to to a moment in my own
childhood when I was playing with the
water guns and my father came and told
me that that was I couldn't do that that
that was unacceptable and I didn't
really understand I was frustrated I was
embarrassed that my father would do that
in front of my friends I he was that he
was the the strict dad I called him
after after Tamir rice have been killed
and we had a conversation and I told him
that I was I understand now I understand
now in a way that I didn't understand
before and thank you even when I was
kicking and screaming and saying that
you were mean and strict and wouldn't
let me you know have fun or be a kid
that these were hard this is I recognize
that these were hard decisions for you
to make so many people in black
community young black men in particular
grew up having the talk and getting the
talk so to speak from their parents but
I remember having conversations with
some of my white friends and and
realizing that that there was no notion
of ever having to have a conversation
about how to interact with with police
who you are in the context of the larger
criminal justice system we can't move
forward I think and have an honest
conversation about race in this country
unless we're we're grounding these
conversations in an understanding of how
each of us in among our differences
navigate the world and understand you
know see that may potentially see the
same thing but understand it differently
we have this sort of rugged
individualism this meritocracy you know
that we are told we we exist in when
that's not really the case in that you
know we have a lot of different people
we're starting from there very different
places in life as a result of their
class as a result of the agenda as a
result of their their race and and we
have a difficult time as Americans I
think contextualizing that and
understanding the sort of socio
historical realities that have shaped
our contemporary existence and so I
think it's hard for us to be honest
about where we are if we're not honest
about where we've come from